tracy ann foley was just like every
other stay-at-home mom in her boston
neighborhood her husband was a harvard
graduate who worked as a consultant
every day she would drive her kids to
school and soccer practice then once
they got older she took a job as a real
estate agent nothing about tracy or her
husband donald seemed out of place they
were just a friendly canadian couple who
were living the american dream white
picket fence and all that was until late
june 2010 when their whole world came
crashing down you see tracy and donald
weren't a normal couple at all their
real names weren't even tracy and donald
it was elena vavilova and andre bezrukov
they were russian deep cover spots from
serbia who spent their entire lives
living alive donald didn't care about
his consulting firm tracy didn't care
about pta meetings or the soccer matches
she drove her kids to it was all a cover
and it had been good enough to hide
their identities for more than a quarter
of a century the truth was elena and
andre had met and fallen in love in
their university in serbia way back in
the early 80s they got married and
picture spending their lives together
but then the kgb came knocking they
wanted to know if elena and andre would
be willing to serve the communist cause
from behind enemy lines both elena and
andre agreed so they started training at
the kgb academy they learned english
they lost their accents they studied
american culture like a high school
student would study science then they
moved on to spycraft surveillance
counter surveillance combat and coding
their training prepared them to become
something we now call sleeper agents
agents who spend years decades crafting
deep cover stories that keep them hidden
in plain sights they spend decades
gathering information sending it to
their superiors and if the time ever
comes to sabotage the enemy from the
inside
after their training elena and andre now
tracy and donald were sent to canada
they staged a meeting at strangers they
dated and then they got married again in
canada using their new canadian
identities now they were ready to start
their real work in america for 25 years
the couple sent information to the kgb
and when the soviet union collapsed they
stayed and kept working for the sfb the
successor to the kgb they had two sons
they went to barbecues and block parties
they never spoke russian to each other
and not even their kids knew who they
really were no one suspected the thing
until they were betrayed in 2010 elena
andre and eight others were arrested
they were later swapped for american
spies captured in russia
since their inception every spy agency
has its own specialties for the cia it's
overthrowing governments and installing
a pro-american leader for israel's
mossad it's assassinating its enemies in
broad daylight and disappearing without
a trace but for the kgb it was
infiltrating america and the west unlike
any foreign government had done before
this is the story of the kgb and the
soviet union super spas
it was march 13 1954 soviet russia was
in the middle of the fight for its life
on every side people wanted to see it
fall at the time the soviet union had
over six different intelligence agencies
and it was a constant headache no one
shared information no one told anyone
else what they were doing and things
just couldn't go on like this so the kgb
was born a combination of all these
agencies under one man ivan the
bonebreaker ivan siroff an
ex-intelligence officer was known as the
guy who could quote break every bone in
a man's body without killing him end
quotes he passed on all of this
ruthlessness onto his new baby the kgb
under seraph the kgb became one of the
most feared intelligence agencies in the
world the sword and shield of the
communist party whatever the rulers of
soviet russia wanted the kgb would get
it done at its peak it had more than 480
000 active members
born from some of the darkest most
bloodthirsty agencies in the world the
kgb was here to make its mark and i
wasted no time doing
that juan lazaro had a very fulfilling
life born in peru he was a karate black
belt news photographer and the husband
of a popular tv reporter vicky palazz in
1985 the young couple decided to try
their luck in america so they moved to
new york there he got a phd and started
teaching political science he seemed
like a typical immigrant who got lucky
he was living the american dream the
only problem was the real one lazaro
died back in 1947 when he was just three
years old so where did this new
successful wand come from he arrived in
peru in 1973. according to records he
had a passport from uruguay once he
moved to america he wasted no time
publishing reports and articles at his
new role as a professor he called
america's wars in iraq and afghanistan
money making ploys he criticized every
part of american foreign policy this guy
did not hold back and his students loved
him for it he was as controversial as
they came no one suspected him to be
anything else other than what he was but
you guessed it one was actually a kgb
spy named mikhail anatalievich the
perfect example of a deep cover sleeper
agents and the man responsible for
creating these d cover agents was yuri
drazdoff under yuri's watch kgb spies
underwent years of training to transform
them into flawless americans europeans
and latinos kgb agents were browsed
through cemeteries looking for names of
babies or children who passed away and
new identities would be created from the
dead for the would-be sleeper agents
this was before the internet made their
job so much easier under these new
identities detailed stories would be
created for each agent a birth
certificate would be printed the church
near the cemetery would be paid off to
erase the death record and suddenly
these identities would come back to life
30 years later these illegals would be
grown to the bone if they even just
spoke russian in their sleep they would
be immediately disqualified but unlike
hollywood wants us to believe these
spies had pretty boring lives in every
sense they lived the regular joe's life
they worked got fired had kissed
divorced went to pta meetings and play
dates they never did any killing or
kidnapping that just wasn't their
mission instead they forgot everything
about their soviet heritage and they
just played the waiting game if they had
interesting information to share they
would pass it on to moscow but they
never went out looking for trouble but
if russia ever needed someone in america
to sacrifice themselves in the name of
the soviet union they would be the ones
to do it they were sleeper agents just
waiting to be woken up closer to sylvia
europe the sleeper agents there had more
action they would infiltrate anti-soviet
groups they would stir up conflict
behind enemy lines and no one did
sleeper agents better than the kgb and
even today there are probably still
sleeper agents waiting to be activated
in the us in fact there are more russian
spies in america than ever before even
if the illegals program wasn't as useful
as planned it's still one of the kgb's
greatest and longest lasting successes
1994 the year one of the most famous
double agents in history was finally
caught aldrich ames didn't start out his
cia career planning on selling secrets
to the kgb he was a pretty average cia
counter-intelligence officer he didn't
make any shocking discoveries or save
the war from nuclear war for 31 years he
went to work logged in his hours and
left more often than not he would make
stupid mistakes
his career wasn't going anywhere he was
stuck in an expensive divorce and it
felt like he would never make it out on
top the only thing he was good at was
helping the ca weed out soviet embassy
staff who could be working for the kgb
sick of living an average life sick of
being a sucker aldrich desperately
needed a win he needed money so he
hatched a plan he reached out to a
contact in the soviet embassy in 1985
and he said he would share important cia
secrets in exchange for fifty thousand
dollars the information he planned to
sell wasn't really that important but it
could be checked out and validated the
soviets agreed his debts were paid his
divorce finalized aldrich ames could
breathe a sign of relief except he had
just given the kgb everything they
wanted they now have proof he was
selling secrets to the enemy and they
could use that proof to blackmail him
into giving much more by late 1985 ames
was handing over the names of top
american spies in the ussr and they all
started disappearing suspiciously
quickly every time he handed over a name
the kgb handed him an envelope filled
with cash in the nine years this went on
he took over 4.6 million from the kgb he
used it to buy a house cars go on
vacations all the things most people
know you shouldn't buy with illegal
money and people started noticing there
was no way he could afford all of this
with just his salary when the caa came
knocking he denied everything he even
passed two lie detector tests just
because he had been friendly with the
examiner by 1994 aldrich ames had
exposed over 100 american spies in the
soviet union after the fall of the
soviet union he handed over the name of
every american agent in russia overall
it took nine years for object aims to be
exposed it was one of the biggest
embarrassments in cia history and the
kgb's greatest success aldrich aims was
found guilty and sentenced to life in
prison without parole he is still in
prison to this day but he wasn't the
only american double agents near the
peak of the cold war the kgb had an
insane amount of these informants around
the world
[Music]
back in the kgb's glory days it had a
very special units with very special
permissions to carry out top secret
missions it was called the directorate
of special tasks this unit specialized
in what they called liquid affairs also
known as targeted assassinations like in
all the best action movies these guys
were ruthless innovative and had
murdered down to an art form one of
their most infamous agents was a man by
the name of boron stashinski he killed
two anti-soviet activists in west
germany using a poison mist gun just
like modern day pepper spray this poison
mist gun sprayed a cloud of cyanide gas
near the victim's face they would inhale
the gas and a few minutes later they
dropped dead
it was just another normal day when
georgie markov stood waiting for his bus
in london georgie was a communist
defector who fled to england from
bulgaria he stood quietly at the bus
stop as a man brushed past the man
passing by dropped his umbrella and it
hit georgie in the leg but the man
quickly apologized grabbed his umbrella
and moved on georgie thought nothing of
it four days later georgie markov died
he has suddenly gotten sick and was dead
soon after his autopsy found a 0.2
milligram pellet of rice sin in his leg
right where the umbrella had hit him
ricin is one of the most deadly poisons
in the world the pellet had delayed its
release but once it entered georgie's
body he didn't stand a chance
it's no secret that kgb loved using
poison to get rid of his targets almost
every successful kgb assassination used
some type of poisonous gas or powder so
when nikolai klokov was sent to kill the
leader of an anti-communist group who
lived in west germany poison was his
first choice this time it was a
cigarette pack that worked like a
suppressed gun only instead of regular
bullets it fires cyanide rounds no
matter where it hit the target it would
be deadly fortunately for today's target
nikolai suddenly grew a conscience he
warned him about the attack and almost
immediately defected to the us
not everyone was that lucky though over
the years kgb assassinations killed
hundreds of people from ex-agents to
defectors to political opponents and
anti-communist activists and as the
years passed all this talk about being
the best the most feared or the biggest
intelligence agency in the world must
have gone to his head because in 1991
the leaders of the kgb made a decision
that would change the history of the
soviet union forever
[Music]
it was august 1991 four months before
the soviet union would collapse and the
world would be changed forever the
leader of the kgb vladimir khrukov was a
die-hard communist he lived and breathed
communism in his mind the soviet union
was the greatest empire in the world and
now president mikhail gorbachev the
leader of the soviet union was becoming
too soft he let germany reunify he held
talks with the enemy it was unacceptable
and vladimir kukov would be the one to
save the communist party so in late 1990
krukov started recruiting soviet leaders
to join in on his plan they would
overthrow gorbachev and place a new
stronger leader in his place the kgb had
been invincible for years
krukov must have thought there was
nothing he couldn't do but he was
massively mistaken they arrested
president gorbachev stormed the
parliament buildings in russia but
ultimately their plan failed as
punishment the kgb was disbanded four
months after the coup the soviet union
fell
now on its own russia set out to create
a new intelligence agency this agency
will become known as the sfb but you're
just gonna have to subscribe to see that
feature video
[Music]
[Music]
you